Steve isn't Oklahoma hey Steve welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Steve there you
are hi Steve how are you yes sir yes sir
your podcast and AM 1640s real popular
here in Oklahoma I've got a quick
question okay um Dave you teach to get
an apartment rent uh-huh while you're
saving for a house how bout if I was to
take that rent the time and the money
and to purchase a fifth-wheel that way I
would at least own something in lieu of
renting and it would be in my pocket
when I'm done are you gonna pay cash for
it oh well no no I wouldn't not tell you
to go into debt no not not even if it
don't tell you there's no not even I
never tell you to go into that the only
thing I don't scream at people for debt
on is because here's the thing when you
rent the money has gone each month but
you don't own anything that's going down
in value a fifth-wheel will lose 80% of
its value in about three years
god yeah I mean it goes down there like
a toilet I mean just like money going
straight down a toilet and so if you
bought a used 5th wheel and you pay five
or ten thousand dollars for it in cash
and you wanted to live in that instead
of paying rent yeah if you want to do
that that's fine because it's pretty
well already taking the tail kicking but
if you go buy a 45 or an $80,000 fifth
wheel a super nice one it's gonna be
worth ten thousand bucks in 20 minutes
and you're gonna have been paying
payments on it all that time so you took
a double yet you took the hit on the
payment and you took the hit and the
loss in value so if you're gonna buy a
super cheap when the idea is not a bad
idea as long as you're not married or if
you are married your wife thinks this is
an adventure mine would not and so it's
just a matter you know it's nothing
wrong way that understand mine wouldn't
but you know you just got to talk that
through and everybody's got to be good
with it but if you're a single guy and
you want to do something like that
that's fine I know one single guy went
bought a $3,000 mobile wide double-wide
double-wide mobile home
3000 bucks now this is a trashy mobile
home okay there ain't much to it for
three grand folk I'm just saying there's
not holes in the floor but it's closed
right and he lived in the stinking thing
as a single guy paid cash for it while
he saved up and built a $250,000 house
by the time he's 27 years old now that's
what's known as a stud right there if
you can do that if you can pull that off
but again I'm not too snobby to do that
and my wife's not too snobby but she's
just not likely to do that maybe we are
too snobby maybe that's what maybe
that's the truth I just need to be I
don't know know what you call it
you're too good that's where I mean I
Hillbillies with you you know you forgot
your raisin no I'm a grape now so shut
up I didn't forget my raisin so it's
just unbelievable so you got to just
think it think it through but anyway
bottom line is you're buying something
if you bought an expensive one that's
going down very very rapidly you're
gonna lose a lot of money and you're
paying payments on it so no I'm not
gonna tell you to borrow money to do
that
but if you want to go like that other
kids away or something and you pay cash
I'd be okay with that